[Music]
okay so we've been tasked with debating
the question who or what should be in
control and we have some wonderful
panelists here so al-mahdi from epfl in
switzerland he's gonna draw on his
expertise on robustness and biological
systems to defend the machines dorsa
Sadiq from Stanford she's gonna draw on
her research on algorithms that interact
reliably and safely well with people to
tell us that both should be in control
and finally Gaia Dempsey she's gonna use
her expertise in reality augmentation to
tell us that humans should be in control
okay so let's start with the most
controversial one which is which got the
fewest number of votes as this morning
so let's hear it for the machines thank
you so yeah I think one is once we will
settle some semantics I think we'll see
that we agree on basically the the made
the main goal so I'll talk in the
premise that we have the common goal of
reserving interest in this in the
universe by interestingness
I mean life and of course humanity and
and the other premise is that like we
have aligned duper intelligence
exceeding human abilities and I believe
it is important to have some but just
like knowledge what we are here in this
panel imagine eight million years ago in
East Africa a bunch of Australopithecus
talking about the prospect of some
upcoming evolved Apes in the Homo genus
able to light fire when they want to
protect themselves from predators and
use sophisticated tools like cilix this
is an understatement for what we are now
imagine them able to talk about the
prospects and plan or the prospect of
even smarter beings with public
education healthcare libraries and the
Internet this is still an understatement
and I think it is important to her to a
knowledge with humility what we are in
the face of what we are talking about we
are talking about alliant are talking
about super intelligence exceeding human
abilities in every task in every task
includes the task of preserving life and
humanity so would have super AI better
than us in deciding and including in
deciding how to save us taking some
counter it with intuitive measures to
preserve us
as much as possible and then life in the
cosmos and in that situation as Elon say
two years ago the problem with humans is
that will be a bottleneck we have a
bandwidth problem in terms of
communication ability so again I'm also
talking about the premise of
biologically constrained humans not
augmented different
biologically constrained humans would be
a bottleneck just as telling the
Australopithecus from 8 million years
ago for some safety critical situation
would you want this mother to have a
cesarean surgery now otherwise she will
die and then the other Australopithecus
would tell you how how much bananas I
would get for that I think this would be
a bottleneck so I think it would at some
point it would become irresponsible to
require human approval or urgent matters
or some existential risk decisions
imagine a fly by a black hole fly by
that tree teens who take earths of
orbits and then the complete the
argument who be convinced for the
decision is so long humans can't read it
and unfortunately interesting things
tend to have a big column number of
complexities not just like a big word to
say incompressible interesting things in
this cosmos can't be compressed in one
tweet importantly despite what the
president of Puerto Rico might might
convey and and so I believe if we keep
discussing and that's I hope what we
will do we will see that Putin for
example in there like if we say that our
safety critical task
well hey I super indigent hey I would
have would need human approval who just
end up with the cute situation where in
fact like if we don't what a naked like
super a I was just like let us think we
really really matter in the decision so
so I think there would be arguments good
arguments on both sides but if we do
things right to preserve from existence
risk would end up but with having super
AI protecting us which I hope we will do
and as just like a last point for those
familiar with the simulation argument
imagine so super intelligent begin keep
thinking about the cosmos and realizes
that whoever the district kid is
creating the universe has been penned
boxing us with rules such as the speed
of light and then finding tricks to keep
this sadistic kid running the universe
and not switching it off just as
Instagram and snapchat is very good
today as having integers not switching
off so that we can keep they told
experiments and then realize that there
would be there would be safety critical
existential risk or which humans would
be just like the Australopithecus unable
to understand and unable to get an
explanation in in one tweet that we can
decide on okay so how will you summarize
your position machines are protectors
biologically constrained humans would be
a bottleneck and irresponsible to manage
safety critical bottleneck humans
biologically constrained humans are a
bottleneck okay bottleneck awesome
so dorsal bring us a little bit closer
and let's let's let's share some of this
control sure this is working right yeah
so I think yes setting assumptions is
right and I agree in terms of what we to
have like a set of assumptions I'm
you're thinking about this problem and
when I was reading the the question at
the time the Assumption I was thinking
was humans still remain we still have
humans and as long it's not like the
case that we have super intelligence AGI
taking over the world like like it's the
case that we still have humans and if we
have humans these AGI are going to be
there like humans created these and are
going to be there for
humans so then if that is the case well
the AGI needs to understand humans
preferences so it goes back to like
Stuart's talk in the morning like there
is there's humans and there is AGI and
there's this kind of what objective
human subjective that's hidden and there
that this hidden objective needs to be
known by the AGI so even if the AGI is
super capable and just like looks at a
person and person might even even with
blinking the AGI decides to go ahead and
like start the breakfast or do
everything for the person like the
blinking is the control that the person
is putting in so that's why a thing it
has to be both like it has to be both
the human and the machine or AGI a robot
kind of coming together and do a task
because at the end of the day the robot
needs to understand human subjective or
humans preferences so that's kind of the
main argument that I think like both of
them should should come together um
there is like another points that I
wanted to make which is kind of this
case that if I have machines and then
they have some objective it's not the
human subjective and they're optimizing
that if that is the case which is
usually the case for us because it's
hard to write or word functions or write
objectives in that scenario we might get
behavior that influences people like if
I look at like my Facebook page and if I
see you like an ad for like shoes like
I'm going to click that I in some sense
you might say bow the Machine is
controlling me like like that ad that
I'm getting is controlling my behavior
but but that's just coming from a
different object if I miss specified
objectives so I think it's just a
problem of like coming out someone else
wrote that objective that there should
be clicking on this ad so at the end of
the day I think it's both of them coming
together
I think the effects of these side
effects that we get from from other
objects as misspecified objectives can
be can be hard I think it can be harmful
and you should think about that and
that's kind of the AI safety problem
that we should be thinking about but at
the end of the day the two come together
okay and what would be the short short
summary of your position our church
summary humans still exist oh ok so
humans still exist that's why they
should be in full control so I also feel
a little bit like some of the other
panelists earlier where I'm not sure
what I selected on the survey that got
me in this arguing this particular point
but I'll do my best
sort of state the arguments for why
humans should retain control and I also
just want to pop you out and say that I
think that control is not very clearly
defined in this statement so there's a
difference between saying you know
should an AGI control resource
allocation globally or should an AGI
control you know all of the sort of
infrastructure that runs our day to day
society and cities and you know
governance versus you know should an AGI
decide my personal individual day-to-day
actions or should I still retain control
of my own free will I think there are
sort of different definitions of what
control mean and that's probably longer
than we have time for in this debate so
if I were to argue for humans being in
control I will also just reiterate the
definition that we started with which is
at the beginning of this conference
you know max you have the definition
that AGI in the way that we're talking
about it here is about replacing all
cognitive tasks all not every single
thing that a human can do or experience
and cognition surely you know the the
the definition of cognition in my view
is not equivalent to ethics empathy
emotion complexity chaos entropy
creativity or meaning and so there are a
lot of things that at this moment in
time the mechanisms for increasing our
capacity is around data processing are
not necessarily equivalent to those
other things and I'll also just say that
I don't believe that ought statements
are I don't believe that all statements
can be derived from his statements so I
do believe in augmenting human cognitive
processes around math and spatial
thinking and logic and reason and you
know I think that there are there's a
lot of ways in which our ability our
input-output ability can be augmented
and that I'm actually a huge proponent
of selective delegation and human
augmentation of certain kinds of control
you know for there are many examples of
things that I don't think humans should
be in control of and that an AGI
do a much better job of controlling but
I I will essentially state the case that
at the current moment humans are the
only realistic agents that we know of
that can act as the connective tissue in
complex decision-making that involves a
set of non logically consistent ethics
and a wide variety of diversity and
human preferences awesome and what and
your position would have the title
inactive tissue connective tissue okay
so I've heard a lot of I think all three
of you have mentioned that maybe what
we're disagreeing about is semantics so
let's just take a few rounds and I'll
ask you a question and just tell me what
were you thinking in the moment if you
if you can remember when you voted for
you know humans or machines or both what
what were you thinking about for example
what did you mean by by humans what
human did you have in mind so let's
start from here I actually think I voted
for both okay but even if you say you
voted for both then what human that you
have what type of human that you have in
mind did you have a human in its current
form a biological human or an Augmented
human or sort of the ideals of humanity
deserve a in the in sort of this
argument that I'm constructing it's
certainly an Augmented human that has
dramatically increased capacity for long
term thinking and that has utilized the
tools you know at our disposal around
augmenting our cognition across all of
these different axes that AI is clearly
far superior and without necessarily
giving up some of the idiosyncrasies
idiosyncrasies that make us interesting
if and I actually really appreciate that
you started your pitch with the idea
that you know we share the goal or we
should potentially share the goal of
preserving and increasing
interestingness in the universe what a
bit what about you bottlenecks which are
the bottlenecks just like
on the on the semantics I just like want
to specify was I mean by control first
then we're going to talk about our
assumptions about machines very very
briefly and then we're going to talk
about what do we mean by control at
least what do we did we mean when we
yeah good i I completely agree with what
he says especially in the conclusion
that for now machines are not able
whatever but I'm not talking about for
now we're not we are not we're talking
on the premise that AGI is there it
exceeds human ability and everything
your question like what what do I mean
by bottleneck yeah is the communication
bottleneck so there are some safety
safety critical tasks or which the time
to explain to a human is longer than the
time required to take the safety
critical decision you would say that
your argument holds as long as we're
talking about humans and probably their
current for but by also human by humans
I mean biologically constrained humans
what about you agree with with the
points that I mentioned and yeah there
are some tasks that of course the
machine is going to be better at it like
when it comes to a self-driving car and
the self-driving safety critical
situation there it might be very
difficult for a person to decide in that
situation and maybe sure the the machine
should take over control in that
situation because you might have better
decisions making decision powers and in
that scenario but there are also other
scenarios where humans are better at it
so when I was thinking of this I was
thinking humans are capable at some
things and then at the end of the day
robots are capable at some other things
and they should augment each other and
also just to add one more point so there
are also tasks that just let's say
machines are very good at it so there
are tasks that my phone can do that I
cannot write like it's an augmentation
of me augmentation of white brain and I
trust it and it does the job but at the
end of the day it's kind of serving me
like it needs to know my preferences
right so there is that relationship
between my preferences and what the
phone does so so that's why I still
think it has to be both because it needs
to know what my objective is going back
to the objective point what about
control so you spoke quite a bit about
different types of control what kind of
control did you have in mind when you
when you were writing your argument or
when you were choosing your position
I'll sort of reiterate what I'm saying
which and I think I'm a huge proponent
of selective delegation
of pretty fast lot of paths and
decisions and so I think you know that
there are specific types of control
related to meaning-making
that I would like to retain control over
and that I would like humans in the
future to retain control over that I
think need to remain under each
individual's personal set of preferences
and that no one else can be a better
expert on them then they are but there
are all kinds of sort of managerial
tasks around individual lives and as
well as a societal you know about
yourself driving cars medicine I mean
all kinds of different areas where I'm
perfectly comfortable just very very
briefly since I also want to open wrap
for the audience any comments that you'd
like to make related to control just
like I mentioned this threshold of tasks
for which the decision is longer than
the time it needs to be taken let's now
take the top that this is the safety
critical decisions for which the time to
explain to a human is smaller than the
tag time needed to take the decision if
HDI exceeds our cognitive abilities it
will be able to convince us or the
safety it will be just cute to say both
yeah let us explain to humans who have
three hours explain to them in a very
good way to take the safety critical
decision destroy the asteroid and then
they will say destroy the asteroid and
they would fail they will feel very
empowered and that's cute I'm okay with
that I'm okay assuming that the machines
are I'm okay with that
assume the end goal is to preserve life
and humanity what about yes well similar
things and then I feel like it doesn't
stop there like the AGI or the machine
can influence you and that's control
right like the AGI convinces you that
you got to do this and that's control
that the AGI has and then you do
something but it doesn't end there like
like you can I feel like from the
control perspective the reason that I'm
thinking humans should also always being
still being control is if the AGI is
influencing you and then you see results
that you were not like expecting or
we're not like hoping for you should go
ahead and change again
change something about it and still be
in control to get different set of
influences so so I'll open it up to the
audience I think Yount Allen if he's
here you had a fantastic question I
think relates quite quite closely to
what Doris I was just saying so maybe
you want to phrase it yourself but
really quickly fish it out from my
memory I think it was how do you
differentiate between informing and and
manipulating when it comes to enough
yeah advising humans who are supposedly
in control I think that's a really
fascinating an important question and
into the nature of perception and the
nature of even observation in scientific
experiments is that the observation
itself changes the outcome of the
experiment so if you sort of turn that
around and say observing any information
is going to change the person seeing
that information so it's there's a very
fine line and I would say that you know
that one sort of pathway that could
support sort of and I think further
research could be done in this area is
in understanding how rationality you
know how we can utilize the AI system
that was presented in the technical
session earlier to sort of like distill
down rational arguments and present them
without too much emotional content but I
think that that's really just the
beginning and something that we should
study much further
no I'll just like to just like it's very
important to keep in mind that were in a
taught experiments will always assume
that machines exceed us in cognitive
tasks like I think it's very good for
the rest of this conference to like go
ahead and stop always repeating it yeah
there must some tasks where the robots
might not be as good as you mean like
we're in a tort experience of course for
now I am my pay my paycheck comes from
finding bugs than like proving that AI
is not reliable and I will keep doing
that I think I think I will die before I
would see AI that's it for which I could
get control so it's very important to
keep this thought experiment that we're
talking in the prospects of AGI
exceeding humans in every ability
including knowing what we would want to
want and this is something about that
okay thank you so much to the panelists
help me thank them
[Applause]
[Music]